okay so this one's for creeps yes wait
so yeah this is an emphasis kind kind of
another murder mystery which kind of
harkens back to the other murder mystery
with the train but it's a few twists and
then doesn't quite explain what of them
all the way they will get that looked
interesting um this is one they go to
Finn and Jake go to this mansions or
this mystery weekend mansion and
everyone gets dressed up and they wear
masks and stuff and then people start
dying and disappearing and that said
that a ghost is gonna possess one of the
bodies and then kill people and it turns
out it was all planned by Finn
but that stuff starts to go wrong and
other people start dying - what's
environments plan and then it turns out
all the plan by Jake but then it turns
out that other things were happening
that he can't explain and Finn just
decides to put in the vault and delete
it and it's which is funny I like not
knowing you know those two islands cuz
as when Jake comes and says oh yeah I
was doing that and they're explaining
everything I'm like there's no way you
can explain the crows and that weird
ghostly thing that come out it comes out
um which I really like the idea of the
Crone's coming out of the picture I
don't know why that really struck with
me I was I was really creative and I
like I was like the look of murder
mysteries um class something the most
important part to me usually amber
mystery it's the mystery I know it
sounds weird but it's like I love the
angles I love how gothic it is um but
when you have to figure out who I
actually do that like yeah okay but I
know that's part that's like what it is
oh well after hearing about you with
Apple thief and not being able to piece
that together me you can see why I don't
like the mystery that you want those
people where it's like usually and my
first thought is correct but then I keep
second-guessing myself and then by the
end I'm like damn but I should just
stuck with my first thought but
yeah but it was fun I like sir the
callbacks - you know - the Train episode
I'm all day specifically you know Jake
is like wait a minute I already did this
before so like cuz initially when I was
first watching and I was like I've
already been down this route you're not
gonna trick us again yada yada yada and
then Jake says that it's like oh good at
least they know that this has already
been done and they're telling us yes
we've been down this road and it's I
don't think it would have worked if they
didn't have that extra element that they
don't tell you one thing the ghost was
or one way yeah the green one or the
crows I think by having an extra element
and not explaining it and keeping a
lynchin mystery and I kinda like because
that sort of like the extra thing to
throw in there because if they did keep
it just
Finn and Jake and Jake pranked him again
even though Finn was trying to it say it
would be okay like really okay by having
that one extra element it's like ooh
what are they gonna do with this so yeah
I I like that Oh hopefully they do
something with that although it again it
almost gotta be funny if they don't but
you know for a for an adventure time
episode some creepy imagery and that
yeah you got like PB melting yeah and
like bits of other people on the wall
obviously blown up in the closet
ripped apart yeah I mean is that some
pretty grim I mean I want to say like
hey this should be PG territory or if it
whatever but at the same time it's like
yeah it did get kind of intense I on
some of the imagery um but nothing
nothing quite too far uh so yeah I mean
yes fun I mean it's not like what no no
it's an LSP back to being funny now that
she's not the main focus yeah but there
were one or two jokes I went a little
too oh yeah the whole brands like you
know okay you can you got got this you
know but no bite especially my favorite
something about the yell like when
cinnamon bun was dead just the way she
was screamin I mean like really good
yells um and again for the most part
when her lines were short and quick
and you know those were the best because
I think that actor can keep that voice
the funny isn't the inflections of
oh really okay he can focus on when the
inflections would be the funniest one
their short lines I think um and the
only other thing I'll say that I also
telling you beemo sounds way too much
like a girl in order for it to be a boy
I just I cannot by the bets a boy and I
know it's a female it does the voice
that's yes I can be most neither they
switch off between male and do they do
they say so they're like look in this
one they said well yeah they brought up
he and all that stuff they did kind of
bounce back and forth I think that's cuz
BMO's just de BMO is a kinda like gooder
and cooter Darrin goonter gunther that
that's it I'll stare about how to say a
Gunther and Gunther uh how they just
sort of switch back and forth kind of
yeah okay oh that makes sense
XML although it was like in while those
geeky Star Trek film full of books or
whatever it's like there's Espada of
datas cat is a boy or a girl I'm saying
all depends in the first three seasons
they call it a him but then he gives
birth to kittens and seasons so it's I
think it's just they're like yeah
whatever flexible reality sort of thing
but BMO talk so that's weird don't you
you know what bebop or you know the fact
that's a computer maybe it's like it's
whatever it wants to be exactly you're
talking about a cat okay there's cats
usually usually have one or the other
sex this is a computer it can be either
or hey I saw her they are living things
and they're evolving and that's a good
movie I never to do would be long gone
that's really good you should watch it
not close-ups of Joaquin Phoenix's face
that's weird but it creates this you
know sort of this closeness because it's
only him and that's sort of the idea
that's all in his mind but that's kind
of not in the mind it's a good movie you
should see a Spike Jones is a master and
my wife's actually talking about it
right now talking about how good is we
both really liked it so check it out
this episode's fine
silence say you are you that was your
wife my wife's good okay but the mystery
began one of you is possessed by a ghost
no actually oh yeah yeah not much of a
mystery you are not good at this now I'm
not even creating a mystery jinkies
really
scooby-doo jinkies really you're going
down that route oh yeah bring narrow -
I'm leaking down with a cab
well hey fuzzy I don't even get to come
on Gnomeo
all right Naruto there's the camera
final words before we end this be look
adorable
now kitty violence